se você já se deparou com uma ideia tão
que fez com que você começar a
sentir alguma coisa mexendo aqui dentro
e se perguntasse Por que que não pensei
nisso antes
bom então até teve uma ideia bem
É mas você aí você foi Lembrando que ela
parecia uma outra ideia que você já viu
você foi perdendo o amor ela já nem
parece tão assim
Oi e aí você foi deixando de lá tu e ela
morreu Pois é eu venho convivendo com
gente criativa a vida inteira seja da
música de sai cinema comunicação e eu
posso garantir para vocês elas pode até
negar mas todas já sentirem fecha ou de
alguma forma deixar o que inveja
alimentasse uma das suas ideias
diferente algumas delas eu realmente
acho que a inveja pode te ajudar a ir
ali
o Igor Pode parecer estranho assim
precipitado Por que não tem nem um
minuto e meio que a gente se conhece mas
eu queria começar isso dividindo com
vocês uma intimidade eu acho que vai
ajudar a deixar claro essa minha relação
em fecha e criatividade praticamente a
história da maior inveja que eu senti na
minha vida
e eu tava lá um belo dia curtindo o
momento de microcrédito na time sair do
Facebook quando eu vi um post do amigo
meu compartilhando vídeo e dizendo
genial letras garrafais
eu pensei OK então estamos fazendo nada
tá acredito aí no vídeo
E aí
[Aplausos]
[Música]
E aí
e é eu vi ali mini dinossauros
atravessando um Riachinho bem realístico
né bem feitinha mas eu não sei se ele
subiu muito a minha expectativa Mas eu
achei legal não fica bem frustrado e e
vai até engraçado viu Pense antes mesmo
que que eu tive eu postou isso sabe esse
cara é meu Guru da computação gráfica
para a gente tem que ter alguma coisa
que eu não tô chegando e eu fui atrás
fui lá outros vídeos desse cara os
trabalhos e E aí eu achei um vídeo que
me fez mudar a minha opinião sobre o
vídeo dos dinossauros
e eu percebi que o rio dinossauro não
era três né não era bem real
[Música]
e vocês sacaram
a sacar me queriam Whats pequenas partes
atravessando Riachinho e esse cara sim
um gênio conseguia enxergar nesse vídeo
de Quatis atravessando o Riachinho um
potencial o vídeo de dinossauros
simplesmente dando um tapa do reverse
isso é genial isso é muito
a e é muito louco perceber que a
discrepância que existe entre esse vídeo
de Quatis com mil rios e um vídeo de
dinossauros que naquela mesma semana
aqui dois milhões de fios
e como eu me sentir diante disso um lixo
o lixo uma faça como criativo porque
naquele momento começaram a aparecer
várias telinhas a minha frente e
mostrando todos os trabalhos e que eu
achava incríveis que eu fiz na vida e eu
olhava para ele falava é só uma farsa eu
jamais jamais será capaz de fazer uma
coisa tão boa tão simples tão rápida e
com recursos tão limitados quanto o que
esse sujeito fez
e imediatamente eu tive que sair dessa
forma e pensar como é que eu posso ser
como ele como é que eu consigo enxergar
o mundo assim eu quero fazer coisas
desse jeito e não necessariamente eu
queria fazer aquilo sabe literalmente
fazer um vídeo de artes que você dá o
reverso e direitinho Sauro não mas
conceitualmente Era exatamente isso
queria fazer eu queria ser capaz de
olhar para todos os patches que me
cercam no mundo enxergar o potencial
dinossauro que esse poderão ser e foi
nessa hora que eu entendi como inveja
poderia me ajudar a rir né
a e posso imaginar aqui muitos de vocês
posso estar torcendo rosto e pensando
gente Mas que festa não é legal e aí eu
digo a inveja é um computador acabou
sério a gente precisa desmistificar essa
bagaça para te conseguir além e vamos
deixar algumas coisas bem Claras aqui
primeiramente do ponto de vista social
precisamos entender que invejar é
diferente de cobiçar Ok invejar é você
querer algo tão bom quanto aquilo que a
outra pessoa tem tem como você querer
trabalhar no lugar tão legal conta
aquele que a sua amiga trabalha
isso mexe contigo isso faz com que você
corra atrás de fazer os cursos que você
melhore seu currículo que melhore sua
Network para conseguir emprego no lugar
bacana como dela
e já cobiça é quando você coloca tuas
forças para tentar tirar a vaga dela
e ficou a diferença do Peso dramático
bem isso
Oi e a inveja pode ser tão harmônica que
a gente consegue encontrar exemplos
disso dessas relações na própria
natureza é existem plantas como as
Bromélias as orquídeas que elas estão
sempre tão altas e não conseguirem ter
as suas folhas lambidas pelo solo
contempla se adaptaram e conseguiram se
desenvolver nos galhos das outras
árvores e todos conseguem estar lá no
alto com seu lugar ao sol sem prejudicar
a coleguinha que levando até lá esse é
lindo se harmônico por outro lado
existem as plantas que praticam o
parasitismo são plantas que Muitas delas
não fazem fotossíntese então para
sobreviver elas precisam secar o agir
cobrir outras plantas sugando seu neta
sua seiva sua vida
E isso não é legal a gente não quer ser
parasita né Não não é bacana
bom então vamos voltar com inveja né que
do ponto de vista criativo é importante
deixar claro que invejar é diferente de
copiar como eu falei em viajar você
querer algo tão bom quanto o que o outro
tem então você quer ter dez tão boas
quanto daquela pessoa que você admira
você quer poder olhar para os problemas
e ver soluções tão criativas com as
daquela pessoa então você se permite
olhar com outro olho Daquelas idéias e
do momento que você começa a aprender
com as suas invejas você percebe que a
cópia Ela deixa de ser uma regra ela
virou uma opção
ah e tem um autor que eu amo que o
cálcio é um no seu livro incrível roube
como um artista adoro título adoro livro
recomendo ele falou sobre isso a gente
não devia se limitar a copiar a ideia
nos nossos vidros a gente tem que tentar
copiar o pensamento por trás delas é
sobre isso como ele fala a gente não
quer ser o nosso ídolo a gente quer
pensar como eles Enxergar como eles isso
faz toda diferença eu esse isso na
prática é graças a uma obsessão que eu
tiro por um artista seu nome Michel
gondry
e para quem não conhece o condri é um
diretor incrível e ele brilhou muito ali
entre os anos 92 mil fazendo um
videoclipe esquentar uma história ele
fez videoclipes fantásticos para o Whats
thrips Chemical Brothers Daft Punk Kylie
Minogue e eu jovem vendo tudo aquilo só
conseguia pensar em uma coisa eu quero
ser me chamou ele
é incrível fascinante todas as soluções
que ele tinha a estéticas ideias os
recursos e isso entrava na minha crença
limitante que dizia-se só vai poder ser
como londrino dia que você tiver
acesso ao recurso que o gunder item aos
equipamentos aquele sesko trocentos mil
figurantes equipamentos incríveis como
aquelas câmeras computadorizadas com
movimentos que repetiram as mesmas
movimentos toda a jamais até aquele e
diga o que até hoje beirando os 40 Eu
nunca vi uma de frente mas aquela crença
limitante durou um bom tempo e Graças a
Deus eu saí dela Graças algum drinque
assistindo uma entrevista dele onde ele
tava aprontando sobre as referências
Dele quem foram as pessoas que
influenciaram a ele na juventude Foi
então que ele falou o nome de Norma
McLaren e senhoras e senhores prepare-se
para conhecer uma pessoa incrível
a norma era um diretor experimental que
teve ali um auge entre os anos 50 e 60
skar ele é a personificação do conceito
de gente que faz o que se Norma não tem
uma equipe gigante equipamento se muita
grana para fazer animação ele fazia as
ideias dele de cima do quadro a quadro
direto na película
e esse cara fez obras-primas usando essa
técnica irem da flor nível de
experimentação bola onde ele começou a
fazer a trilha sonora dos filmes direto
na película é Ingrid e ele foi indo além
e ele fez uma das peças que eu sou
fascinado que se chama Canon Canon é o
uma obra de basicamente conta uma
estorinha através de uma coreografia mas
o detalhe peculiar aí é que é uma
coreografia de um homem só sozinho
fazendo algum movimento que ele só faz
sentido quando você pega aquele mesmo
take sobrepõe com ele mesmo conserta
intervalo fazendo com que o cara começa
a interagir com ele mesmo e você vai
entendendo que cada movimento que ele
tava fazendo interage com ele do futuro
e com o olho do futuro é incrível
é um homem uma câmera um estúdio de uma
ideia foi só o que dá uma precisou
para fazer essa peça
e vocês não imaginam para mim também o
que foi sei lá gratificante perceber que
talvez eu não tivesse sido a única
pessoa que senti uma energia vendo esse
filme porque os cinquenta anos depois
que quem não foi lançado não me chama
Andre fez o clipe da Kelly não bebendo
diretamente dessa fonte mas ele tinha
uma personagem que interagia com ela
mesma diferentes looks e naquele momento
eu percebi que sim eu poder fazer desta
muito com as ideias dormir e com
recursos tão limitados quantos que o
normal tinha
e isso foi muito Libertador eu diria um
poder a Dor imbuído Desse espírito Eu
juntei um grupo de amigos extremamente
talentosos extremamente doidos pra gente
fazer um dos projetos experimentais que
eu mais tenho orgulho que é o clipe de o
tempo do nosso planeta de Acaju
basicamente para quem não conhece ele
foi uma experiência ao vivo para os fãs
onde os fãs eles podem interagir com a
banda um tempo real eles Suita vão a uma
hashtag e um grupo de grafiteiros pegava
escrevi o nome deles no painel tudo isso
sendo transmitido ao vivo e atrás esse
painel tava banda fazendo uma
coreografia bem lenta e misteriosa
alguns minutos depois a gente pegou esse
vídeo que elas um transmitido ao vivo
acelerador pela sobre as pessoas ele já
era o clipe tipo as pessoas foram
loucuras faz estar Aliados no Twitter
comentando meu Deus não acredita Acabei
de ver acontecer
o móveis dentro dos meus olhos eu nem
sabia quem crer em meu nome está lá todo
mundo trânsito aquilo era muito
Fantástico né e é muito simples acho que
vai fazer 10 anos agora que a gente fez
esse clipe e até hoje tem gente que que
comenta comigo quanto que ele foi uma
referência como um novo jeito de fazer
videoclipe uma nova forma de interagir
com os fãs Mas o que eu mais a divisa
com as pessoas que ficam intrigadas de
gente não pode ser como é que vocês
conseguiram ter dão cidades diferentes a
banda da velocidade o grafiteiro estava
em outra como que se fizeram isso em
pós-produção não pode ser possível que
só aceleraram o vídeo e resposta curta
aqui a gente tentou fazer algo que o
Norman Mclaren poderia ter feito em 1957
E é claro que não é que existe algumas
restrições acesso a Twitter ou
transmissões ao vivo mas essa da parte
fácil dá ideia Acho que desde então a
inveja tem sido uma parceira firme da
minha rotina criativa e e é muito louca
falou que conheceu eu comecei a perceber
que é como se toda a criação ela fosse
uma criança
e a gente cria com tudo e todos que
vieram antes da gente com tudo e todos
que criaram aquilo que a gente consumiu
está tudo aqui e mesmo que seja sozinha
no seu quarto tem ideia você tá
cocriando com essa galera e isso faz com
que a gente fique mais Alerta a gente
precisa tá muito aberto porque as
referências as inspirações elas
realmente problema de qualquer lugar
Mas voltando ao nosso vídeo dos patches
claro que eu fiquei obcecado entre nas
redes desse jeito tentando encontrar
alguma referência uma pista que me
levasse a ter ideias como ele eu queria
saber que filmes que ele assistiu
recentemente que cineastas que eles
seguem e eu achei a resposta no próprio
vídeo do patinho foi uma pessoa que deu
a ceder nos comentários a pessoa viu o
rei dos cotistas e comentou Nossa
percebi aqui que se você botando reverse
eles viram-me de dinossauros e ele
respondeu o legal isso hein vamos lá
simples assim
eu confesso que eu senti uma alegria sem
aqui dentro do coração de perceber que
essa internet dessa sozinho então nós
que fascinado envio uma co-criação
acontecendo no lugar tão inusitados
quanto os comentários do vídeo Sei lá se
ele se conhecem isso é você Fantástico e
nem assim temos espaço esperando que eu
tenha conseguido desmistificar para
vocês essa relação da Ivete da
criatividade e fazendo um convite para
que você se provoquem a da próxima vez
que virem uma dieta tão que mexa
assim com vocês por dentro que vocês
usem as energia para criar algo que mexa
de volta com outro
e eu garanto vai ser épico e
E aí